I played piano when I was four until I was 18 and then I started violin,...
...and it's a really beautiful way to express passion and it's a great communicator.
I think it's probably the closest instrument you can get...
...to sounding like the human voice.
It's incredibly beautiful and romantic and expressive.
I went to a concert the other day and I found myself...
...silently sitting in the audience crying because it was so incredibly beautiful.
As a performer, you can stand up on the stage...
...and really make people feel things that you want them to feel,...
...and that's what I love about it.
My violin is probably my best friend, it's there for me through everything.
And whenever I'm feeling iffy, I can go play my violin and...
...it distracts me from everything day-to-day.